My name is Caitríona Balfe
I am in Belfast, the movie,
and here's some
Tricks of the Trade
To nail a Belfast accent,
well first thing you have to learn
is how to say ”Bout Ye”
And that means, “How are you?”
But who would even talk to you?
I think you have to learn
to speak really fast
because everybody talks
really fast like this.
If they do get there,
they should get to the moon.
Somebody says here.
Just remember to singsong everything you say.
It did.
Now we have to cut
things out of the papers.
And explain how they got there.
Music's a huge one.
With this project, actually Ken
had sent a playlist of some songs.
I like to sometimes read something
from that time period
or watch some films, and
that was also because
film was such a big
part of this.
I like to do things
like each of my characters wears
a different perfume.
Perfume that didn't feel
like it should have been in
Belfast in the sixties.
That little bit of glamour
brought her to life for me,
and she just felt really familiar.